Taylor Swift yeah she broke quite a few
records in the music industry she was
nominated for song of the year more
times than any other female artist in
Grammy's history most video of the Year
wins at the 2022 VMAs and she's the
highest earning female musician of the
past decade but how much do you know
about her history in film Taylor Swift
has in fact signed on to direct a
feature-length film for which she also
wrote the original script are we joking
here the film is going to be produced by
oscar-winning Studio Searchlight
Pictures the studio behind Nomad land
and the shape of water so yeah her very
first feature and no pressure at all
what brought her into the spotlight at
the studio was her short film all too
well after seeing it it was like a light
bulb went off that yes Taylor Swift
should write and direct a feature film
all too well that was her first time
writing and directing so she was
learning as she went along I cast Sadie
sink and Dylan O'Brien and they could
not have blown me away more what a cast
to guide the actors through this
debilitating heartbreaking emotional
process must have been a really
transformative experience the origin of
this song actually started as a 10
minute version she ad-libbed the entire
thing during a rehearsal and it just
happened to be recorded casual yeah
there were a lot of experimental moments
in her directing style one for example
so it was a very long one take one
camera shot that lasts for a very long
time it was totally different as a form
of Storytelling than anything she'd ever
done before and yeah it's obvious that
she nailed it and a big part of nailing
that process was working with the
actor's natural strengths Dylan O'Brien
and Sadie sink's chemistry was
completely out of this world and she
found them to be some of the most
prepared and professional people that
she'd ever worked with try it a few
different ways all right and that's
saying a lot when you're t-swift are we
right Taylor also said that she never
would have made the film if Sadie didn't
want to star in it but according to
Sadie that wouldn't have been an issue
if she would ask me be a tree in
something I would have said yes like in
a heartbeat Taylor's most important
scene between them was the fight scene
that was the one they didn't cut till
the very end she says you can tell a lot
about a person by the way that they
argue so it was important for her to
highlight that scene she talked to Sadie
and Dylan a lot about their intentions
and said they were so powerful and
emotionally intelligent she just
couldn't cut she had to see it play out
there was like a death clutch as we're
watching this because we're like oh my
God oh my God to say this was an intense
set is an understatement definitely a
different vibe from the set of cats
though although no cats was intense too
only a different kind of intense and
Taylor did learn things from it we know
Taylor Swift is a big cat person I buy
cats I hang out with the cat you adopt a
cat but now we can actually say that
literally and when think he's half
asleep he's always why
before this musical Taylor Swift
wouldn't really consider herself a
dancer and the musical was heavy on
flamboyant cat choreography it was a new
skill she had to work hard to pick up a
lot of the people were either dancers
who learned to sing and back or actors
who learned to dance then singers like
herself who were just learning to dance
as well either way the cast was filled
with creative people from all over the
world who were learning bouncing improv
off of one another and honing their
skills together everybody's working
really long hours of hearsing every day
and it's fun part of these long hours
involved going to cat's school yes
that's a real thing can you imagine
being taught to be a cat by James Corden
somebody get the laser get it get it get
it this was obviously a huge aspect of
becoming a top tier cat for the show I
was just recently named artist of the
decade being the artist of the decade
that she is um but after people see me
lap up milk from that giant saucer I'm
pretty sure they'll take that away she
also wrote an original song for the
movie score because what can't she do
the song in question is called Beautiful
ghosts which was also co-written by
Andrew Lloyd Webber surprisingly it was
a rush job that was written in one
afternoon and what happens when Taylor
and Andrew write a song in one afternoon
it just gets nominated for best original
song at the Golden Globes she's really
come a long way since Valentine's Day in
2009. oh yeah you know we have to go
there five six seven eight I think we're
I think we're okay this role was
actually written into the film because
of the director Gary Marshall he really
wanted her in the movie he would have
written a bigger role for her but she
was already booked and busy this was a
chaotic shoot they were filming in an
actual active High School why not shut
it down we don't know every 30 minutes
there would be bells ringing and
hundreds of students pouring out of
classrooms exactly where they were
filming so talk about inconvenience also
tons of people were screaming at her out
of their classroom Windows because duh
when do you see Taylor Swift on your
school campus ground she may have had a
small scene but it took shockingly long
to get done being green to the acting
scene didn't stop Taylor from doing more
films she wasn't afraid to ask questions
and improve her skills in this movie way
back in 2014. Jeff I ask all the time
just like what can I do differently the
film was a lot more natural for her
because it heavily involved music she
would hang with her co-stars in their
dressing rooms just playing guitar
probably secretly composing a full album
or something this girl is seriously
living breathing and dreaming music at
pretty much all times
of course the documentary
time she was ever
of having a sort of live audience we
never get this in the studio nobody ever
is like
and she was shocked at how positively it
affected the creative process and how
the songs me and the man naturally came
to life Taylor clearly likes to dabble
in every form of performative art Ted
are you are you okay being in this film
hit actually was a pretty special one
since the first time that she heard
poetry and rhyming in her life it was
because of Dr Seuss himself and she was
hooked she got to play Audrey the dream
girl of Zac Efron's character Ted I grew
up and became a songwriter and now I get
to rhyme stuff all the time this was
another character specifically created
for her and she found it hard to say no
because of how freaking adorable the
movie was a little different than the
next time she did comedy in Amsterdam
but we're clearly along for the ride
Taylor Swift has a great sense of humor
that really shines through her role as
Elizabeth Meekins we were laughing
throughout the entire movie but Taytay
not so much going all cool and
professional on set Taylor Swift is just
she was so cool and and just happy we
are sent to the process and just was
able to flow and she got super close
with John David Washington the actor who
played Harold apparently she was sharing
her knowledge about the music industry
and being extremely generous she has a
great knowledge about many great things
so I'm thinking maybe you know she she's
Savvy he said don't sleep on Taylor
she's as big as she is for a reason
um trust us yeah we know but anyway
getting thrown under a vehicle is
totally fine though so that's all we've
got and honestly we're not totally
convinced that Taylor isn't part robot
for real though does this woman ever
sleep she's just all about those
midnights